what happened I heard that you
cried on the TV show the pulse who
actually broke down what happened there
that's terrible i've been doing this
book tour and it get you know it's like
interviews dredging up a lot of stuff
yeah you keep on living and stuff over
and over again asking the same question
and then when I was doing the interview
you know three hours of just thinking of
you know all about my mother and
grandmother I got full for a moment and
I ain't gonna I ain't gonna do what do
you mean you got fooled what do you mean
food yeah well you know you know when
you think about something something that
used to be and something's really close
and dear to you there's no shame about
that well you wrote a horrible thing not
a horrible thing but a very emotional
passage in your book you talk about for
you saw your mother naked by accident as
we all do you said you realize she had
breast cancer or something was wrong
because she had a big scar on her chest
well I came in I I was playing baseball
and I I hit a home run to win the game
so I was excited I ran all the way home
and when I came upstairs we had this
sliding door
and we was always always taught to knock
and stuff you know but I hit the door
mama and I slid the door of him and my
mother didn't have a top on
and I said my and I looked and one of
the right side of the breast was gone
and uh she had the bra with the
chest pad in it and she said Son go and
close the door I hate you later I was
frozen
you know because I just kept looking
and she said close the door
so I backed up and I closed the door and
I went in the back and I asked my
grandmother I said I said granny
from a mother
she said go ask your mother
so I waited a few minutes and I knocked
on the door my mother who was dressed
she said now what is it you want to ask
me son
and I said uh mom what's wrong with your
chest
she's just none of your business
now tell me what you want to tell me
she never wanted me to know and when she
passed she wrote a 10 Page Letter to my
aunt explaining her death you still have
that letter yeah I still have it and
what to do and how to do it
and she had in a letter don't worry
about Bernie Bernie's gonna pass
everybody now that that's a very
emotional story you're telling me right
you know I'm glad to see that side of
you yeah a lot of people think you're
just a funny man well you know what it's
a lot of you know uh how when you when
you are what you are and you and you
just got strength with that ain't no big
thing to me because what you see is what
you get you're strong about that even in
your book you say
the first time you really performed in
public was at a funeral yeah you made
people laugh at a funeral and people
started hiring you because you could
make people laugh at funerals right make
them feel better well I learned about
comedy I played a lot of sports and
sports taught me about getting in front
of Team working all that kind of stuff
but the one thing I taught about comedy
was the strength to go out there and not
be afraid to fail
um okay comedy you only yeah that is the
only that's a good lesson because that's
a great lesson because man you get up on
that stage you're by yourself you're by
yourself you gotta have confidence when
you're talking to your friends in the
living room right there you go if you
can get that mindset see boxing is an
individual sport but a referee a judge
can determine your fate
golf you could miss a putt and might hit
a a Pep Boy or something like that or
the wind take it to the right or left
but comedy you can't blame no damn body
foreign